now yeah i just uh you are the minority
leader of the senate i just want you to
know that right just in case you're not
aware
you're going to be the majority leader
what's that i'd rather be the majority
leader yes that's right well well
you have uh you've been both i've been
both and i like the majority leader
better
but do you i mean i thought in some ways
maybe being the minority leader would be
kind of fun because it's not your
president you don't have to necessarily
he's not your party and doesn't allow
you to be a little bit more of a rogue
yes
so there's some fun to being the
minority leader well when you're the
majority leader and you have your
president of white house you have to
carry all these heavy buckets of water
and when you're a minority leader you
can splash a little on the way so you
don't have the same responsibility you
don't have the president to do what to
deal with but
he's not of your parties you're not
carrying all the burdens for that
president senator mitchell does a great
job as a majority leader but he'd be
outstanding as a minority leader
and you heartily recommend him for that
job
can he put you down as a reference would
that be all right i've already given uh
i've called a lot of people
you're working very hard on that i think
you would be very good well well one of
the things uh as a minority leader uh
you disagree quite often with the
president with the exception of nafta
you probably disagree with president
clinton on just about everything
no i think you look at the crime bill he
agrees with us on some parts of the
crime bill
and you look at japanese trade i support
the president i think we have to let the
japanese know that we're serious about
this it's a two-way street
we want access to their markets so i'm
supporting the president there
foreign policy uh you know we
you disagree a lot with him on foreign
policy
but you know but we're but i think where
we where we understand it why we support
the president but i think it's american
leadership
in bosnia i've been supportive of the
president i think we've waited too long
and i said that about the last president
we've let uh 200 000 people
die 10 000 in sarajevo and 2 million
refugees bosnia is an independent nation
remember the united nations
and it took the death of 67 people on
the fifth of february to wake the
international community up so uh
but i i want to be supportive we only
have one president at a time
our role is the loyal oppositions not to
obstruct the president that's not the
role of the republican party
and we support the president when when
we think he's right and uh we'll
continue that do you think there are
ever times when you disagree with them
and it's
you're doing it as a matter of policy
it's politics do you ever do it when you
say to yourself
you ever thought to yourself gee that's
actually a pretty good idea but i'm
gonna have to oppose him on this
well
i don't i don't think yet i mean
healthcare let's take well we don't have
time for that but let's take health care
but
i think that's a good idea healthcare
reform but it's so complicated uh well
you actually went uh i i commend you on
this you managed to come up with a chart
minutes after the state of the union
address uh
he went
mr specter
you and arlen spector were
scribbling furiously i'm sure as he was
speaking but you went on the air and you
said that it was uh
part of your point was you showed this
very complex chart of the healthcare
plan and i was wearing the time did you
make that chart a little more complex
than it had to be just to uh
just to get your point across no in fact
we left out a lot of things because uh
the chart would've been too big for the
room
so we tried to shrink it a little bit
you get it on camera
and uh
are you sure about that now because i i
looked it at the top dana do we have the
the tape
actually i think we have the uh
the tape of uh
senator dole's appearance can we just
roll that because i'm curious about
something i thought you made it a little
more complicated dana could we roll that
please
my colleague senator arnold specter of
pennsylvania
has prepared a chart of what the
healthcare bureaucracy would look like
under the president's plan and i'd like
to show you this chart it's a great big
chart it contains 207 boxes
it would take a long time to fully
explain it
and frankly i have difficulty
understanding it myself dana could we
yeah could we yeah just freeze that
thank you very much let's just get a
little closer on this chart i'm just
curious about something and just take a
close look there that's you if you could
yeah now just zoom in just a little more
could you zoom in yeah see you've got
you got it
you've got
those are nc double a match ups you've
got
that's it that's where we got the idea
there is no reason for those ncaa
matchups to be in there
i'm sorry i i believe in uh everyone
having yeah he said to put him in there
so we did right i learned a long time
ago don't listen to andy he's got a lot
of bad ideas well i've listened to him a
lot and some of his ideas are better
than others but
i'm sorry andy
i apologize
no but uh you uh you you have gone to
battle in healthcare you actually you
actually uh i think that uh hillary
clinton has done quite a good job though
even though you have your differences no
doubt about it we we've started down the
road together i've had a lot of health
care in my lifetime i've spent a lot of
time in hospitals
i'm the prostate pinup boy in uh
washington d.c
i've
you know i've
you don't have to say it that way well
i survived prostate cancer so i know all
about it and i tell men over 40 or 50
get that little psa test or two tests i
won't go into the other one but the psa
test
is one that uh but so i understand that
people have problems in america and i
think i'm just hoping i'm just as
sensitive as president miss clinton but
we have a different
focus on how we get there
but you actually do you think that she
could should be on the cabinet do you
think she should have the right to be on
the cabinet in the cabinet yeah
yes i think she should be in the cab in
fact i told the president i'd introduce
a bill
to change the law that would allow her
to be in the cabinet
but he hadn't called me back
wow that's funny he returns all my calls
so quickly
you